hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play x mortis now
this is a flash game that some of you
may have heard about because it's
actually quite old but there is a sequel
and uh another sequel in the work
they're all called sequels anything that
comes after this squinch Oh Lord alright
there's a whole different story but
anyway there's the one game that I
actually tried a long time ago but I
couldn't finish because I was scared oh
the little bubble blowing baby also you
might have noticed that the quality of
the webcam is much better I just got a
new webcam yes it is pretty incredible
I'm very happy about it I'll tell you
all that later I'll just leave you all
guessing what it could possibly be
but either way thank you so much for
joining me and let's get going
I remember the memories that this brings
back I never finished I got in the front
door
but there's gonna be more I remember
those now does the other one I think
there's one more I forgot about those
yep okay should be it X more TAS yeah
okay that wasn't you wake up in the
woods with a lump on your head you can't
remember how you got there all you can
recall are the dreams it's late cold and
you are unsure of where you are exactly
fighting through the headache your game
your focus you see a house in the
clearing and decide to shelter there
anything is better than freezing to
death in the woods well I can think of a
few things better I can figure I could
think of a few things worse
okay the woods so this is a lovely
little house in the middle of the woods
where the sky is some weird ominous el
scape of diabolical nature so obviously
you go into the house
yeah this is about as far as I got when
I played a hallway shrouded in shadows
these stairs lead up to a second level
yeah I didn't get very far
only because you know a lot of people
discredit these games these games scare
the crap out of me
I don't know why what it is about him
but they just do okay
pentagram lovely one - oh is this some
more dirt one two three four five one
two three four five one two three four
five like it was making an upside-down
star anyway I don't like this game I
just don't like these games
oh because I know that these type of
games love to have things pop up at you
so you walk around every corner as if
it's gonna happen alright the handle
turns with the door refuses to budge Oh
okay okay that was a cellar entrance so
obviously I gotta go the hallway leads
off into darkness good let's go down
there I like that idea
grandfather clock is ticking away in the
corner that's lovely loveliness Oh
what's this no it's just a clock wait is
it supposed to signify something it's
what 113 no it's one in the more two in
the moon like one in the morning I don't
know door seems to be locked
ah not microwave is dripping blood
alesis this this house is somewhat
modern ha oh it's a head ha ha ha a
severed head it appears to be a fresh
kill wherever the killer is he will
probably be back soon and I don't want
to be here when he returns Wow Oh aah
aah
poor guy all right ok whoa what was that
Oh a blood-stained knife you should
probably arm yourself with a slightly
larger weapon are you kidding me it's a
brass it's a spiked knuckles knife combo
why wouldn't you want that I want I want
that oh okay that's I don't I didn't
mean a sorry guy I'm gonna get me okay I
don't see anything else in here um I
can't open the bottom on sluices I bet
if I try to get out all front door is
locked oh this is not back hopes a
tattered diary may 24th oh my god if you
want to read these pause the video I
don't have time to go through all of
these pause the video here pause the
video here pause the video here my
goodness as great as my voice is I don't
have the time to dedicate to reading
this diary and pause the video here
anoint me Lord fillet ooh what the
exporter shall make the world remember
what was and I will be integral to
reinstating what will
okay a group of campers oh okay
immortality' beyond patience so lovely
lovely that's that's great
that's great more blood something's been
dragged through here it's a fireplace
what would be dragged through the
fireplace see a little shiny there no
it's one of those clicky games where you
just click everything blood stains these
chairs nothing of interest nothing
besides the book okay let's go back now
I'm mr. had how you're doing are you
doing okay let's just get out here yes
please excuse me bye bye bye bye bye I'm
leaving I'm leaving
Emily how can I get out why am I going
upstairs oh I don't want to go here's
who uh
moonlight streams through this window
how romantic
how romantic everybody out there this
door has no handle
well isn't that useful it's also like
Ashburn I don't like I don't like this
oh did you hear those delightful
hahahaha oh shut up
what is that what was that ah oh oh what
is that was that is that something what
seems to put seems to be like blood god
I swear these I'm a 1 like these games
ok key I got a key good that's good
Norton airy yeah ordinary nothing in
this house is ordinary thank you very
much ok i got a key which obviously goes
to oh ok it's just it's just a phone
okay
oh I think that's that squeaking why is
there ceiling on the blood how the hell
did someone plug it on the roof that is
a excellent question and I'm gonna get
the hell out of here because I hate this
place shut up that thumping is not cool
brah all right so the key must go to
that other door that was locked down
this way a frickin I freakin hate
oh this looks good lose an arm why house
turning in a graveyard ya know hey I see
you MIT's our eyeballs are you looking
at
were you looking at bra broham bro-heem
Ian oh okay I don't see anything
clickable in here see no electricity in
the house that's good
oh hi Xavier ray AM Rahim okay you can
pause here unless there's some code in
here that I'm missing X mortis which
loosely translates to the dead
okey dokey my daughter pause here Gwen
fleeting moment Gwen thank you daddy
rised and convulsed in agony while all I
could do was just watch and sob from the
corner in her dying breath the real Gwen
locked eyes with me and spoke thank you
daddy
ah I hear voices cursing my actions okay
you're still staring at me buddy very
unnerving about this sculpture no
kidding it's kind of staring at me okay
um
the word remember is smeared with blood
on this mirror Kat oh I'm trying to
click oh hello ooh what is this hey
what's going on here what's going on
here what is what is happening what's
happening brah I don't know I don't know
I don't know I don't know what that's
all about must be some puzzle that I
overlooked at some point did you hear
something
do you hear like a squishy dripping
sound maybe maybe okay I got that one
damn I don't think there's anything else
here besides that one that's where that
one it's just that one glowing one and
this shelf right here and um that's it I
don't know I I don't know how to solve
this in okay let's just get out here
that statues creeped me out okay so if
ie there's nothing here maybe oh wait
maybe you have to do something like this
looks like IA XII 12 3 but of this
hearing random noises and it's freaking
me the hell out
okay so ah it's one o'clock so one 12 1
1 1 x No 1 X 1 1 no I don't know I feel
like this is a puzzle this is a clue to
a puzzle of some sort that I should know
if it's 1 o'clock 1 0 0 or I it's it's
12 I don't know I don't know I can't
bear it out I can't figure it out
cover it out
I'll go back to that in just a second
it's a lot more kitchen - hey buddy
Tommy cigarettes dummy whoo there's an A
in his skull isn't there there's an A
that isn't a isn't it okay it's also
phone fire extinguisher in a corner and
that's it
there was nothing in here right as far
as I know there was nothing nothing not
a hell of a way like this wave Italy I
don't like it I like this game I don't
okay you're still tearing at me okay I
got that okay there's got to be
something here like what is abcdefgh i
okay i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i
no oh my god oh my god no okay
enough panicking I'm a man I will solve
this this guy's still staring at me but
that's okay maybe there was a clue in
this book 1878 could be a flu gr I don't
see any numbers searing noises okay I'm
just gonna go out I don't think I don't
know what's going on here okay all right
maybe there's something else like just
what about this one two three four five
one four to five three and there's a B
in the middle is that relating to the
book 1 4 2 5 3 I don't know 1 2 3 4 5 I
I don't know I don't know I don't know
these things these things I do not know
shut up
remember wait a minute remember the lows
remember written on the blood in blood
on the thing I'll come back to that let
me go back upstairs just a double check
shut up shut up shut your face shut your
face
oh good golly okay all right
going back back now okay
there was also oh well about this safe
maybe I got a code from
so if you go around the pentagram it was
1 4 to 5 3
no no Graham 18 wha [ __ ] I forgot the
number
1876 1870 well I don't 18 1872 I don't
remember what the number was I don't
remember her why don't I remember why is
the wise rufle' of swinging I don't know
I don't know it was a I think I tried
the numbers that I got I'm not sure I'm
just being creeped out right now okay so
this was one one four two five three
that was I had the right order on that
so it wasn't that that wasn't the code
but if this number on the book is
different
we might be that 1878 that was it 1878
so let me try that yes
tops yeah by 1878 let me just double
check one more time Kihara 1878 1878
1878 1878 1878 ew8 a TWA 80 day daily
DeMuth shut up sharp your damn things
yeah I hate this house 1878 1878 18w atw
1878 he didn't every eight shut up shut
up
oh come on oh god I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't know I'm lost
I'm lost I'm lost I'm lost I'm lost I'm
lost almost okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
figure this out I'm gonna figure this
out and get back to you guys once the
once you know I find something worth
helping so here I go into the future oh
wow okay I found it there was um the
thumping I was hearing her in this room
I knew I heard something there was a
thing on the ceiling I didn't see that
before
Oh could that be where the thumping is
coming from yeah yeah yeah definitely
let's um let's go up Oh
what is that what is that a torso oh the
torso hung up by the arms has been
ripped to shreds you can you wretch at
the mere sight yeah no kidding okay why
did I come up here and why was there
thumping a cymbal is written in the
blood looks like an F kinda an F there
was an a carved into oh is there
something on the arm hang on I gotta
write these down the A's was on the head
there was an F on the torso with a F and
then there might have been something on
the arm I don't know alright so symbol
written in the blood of this poor soul
yo whatever man
oh hello ah three four eight nine three
four eight nine that probably code to
the safe I'm gonna go get that now I see
is there anything else that I need to
know here can I get out of this stupid
attic good god man haha game man this
game I swear
shut up squeaky lantern okay three four
eight nine enter yes okay
got something here oh it's a heart hey
wait hey hang on okay X titled X mortis
oh it's the actual book good good
oh my okay um you guys can read this
again pause if you need to read it pause
here blah blah blah looks like some
interest or I would love to read this
later on but I just don't have the time
now I want to get through this whole
game in one video the Vallejo Vallejo
corporeal form same guys have Xavier
reanimate 1890 so a few years after he
killed Gwen or whatever her name was
and a heart it appears to be a human
heart made appeared to be all human
heart and that looks like an f2 but I
don't know I swear that looks like
enough
ah maybe that's it I don't know it looks
like an F but it also I'm actually gonna
copy down what it actually looks like
could be a tea or something or an e
maybe he could be an e got two it's got
three up three things I was not the only
thing in here good let's um get out of
here plays thank you shut up thumpy I'm
done with you now I am done with the
thumpy and you can go to hell and burn
burn Isaac we're all gonna burn for what
we did to you shut up okay so if if
there was a harm that means there yes
guys stop staring at me that means if
these symbols so if I that wasn't an E
that doesn't look like an e looks like
the F I mean I swear guy an AF f e or f
fe fe what's the deal here there's got
to be something that I'm missing here
has just gotta be something that I'm
missing all right all right okay gotta
be something what else did I get
I just got the book and another symbol
was written on the wall I didn't get
anything useful from the safe I don't
know let me go back to um gotta be
something I'm missing the guy it was an
a on his forehead right this guy hasn't
yeah it isn't a symbol on his forehead
in a shape of an a maybe there was
something else in this room consist
covered in blood and all that it's quite
literally blood everywhere
no man I don't know no huh no no no no
all right I'll be back I'm Way over time
when I usually do something to hurry
this up a bit
I'll be back I'll be back in a second
Wow ah ah coming back in okay I found it
I found um the simple there I knew there
had to be one on the body part because
there were one on every other body part
and um it looks like a you uh uh it's an
upside down a hang on I there was there
was a a who's that a V I am in okay um
there were two A's and two F's by the
look of it I mean I think I think that's
what I'm seeing here I see a F F a F a F
maybe was it FF e F I don't know I don't
know ah maybe yeah damn it okay ah it's
got to be something I'm missing here
there's got to be something that I'm
missing here okay shut up
maybe was something I adore yeah maybe
it was an attic here too
ah okay the door is now ajar how the
door didn't turn into a jar you so phony
haha the little girl
what uh-oh how can the blood still be
wet
don't ask okay okay all right then ha ha
ha ha
wake up did I fall asleep oh yeah I
must've been so tired just fell asleep
in the puddle of blood that seems like
something that I do I mean this house
seems pretty modern for it to be one
that you know 100 years ago so what one
now wait no there had to be something
else what did I miss here was that head
I just come up here to get knocked out
by a little girl such a big baby I fell
asleep I don't know oh if that door
opened up maybe I can go down to the
cellar now maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe
maybe maybe maybe baby baby baby
maybe baby just get me out of here get
me out of here can I can't I can't
Lola's probably not a good thing
look it's uh an old air filtration unit
but the ducting runs away from the
actual house yeah looks exceptionally oh
look an axe haha my axe now mine chop
chop
let me ask you a question ha ha I have
an axe now oh no oh no now you look at
smelly put on some axe oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no no no the door is locked
well I have an axe I have an axe think
the axe is your ally yes I do
Oh oh this does not look good okay your
first
huh a symbol appears on the forehead
then that must mean this is the fifth
sacrifice if I'm not one of the campers
and Who am I I can't be no please no oh
that makes sense
I just I jumped it frigging head off
okay
look a key I can use this to unlock that
door back there hey guy hey buddy
oh just came okay so I'm gonna go
forward here Oh a pentagram haha God
[ __ ] a patrol have served us well now
serves again
become the hand of his Maltese devout
the concern life of five knots of
relative entropy
mirabela the cell survive what was what
is and what would be I don't know the
order these come in okay this was the
last one no get out there no no I didn't
want to bug that one Oh God oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no it's gonna kill me no
I know no I didn't know
oh god oh god oh no no I'm gonna die no
okay okay good okay so the first one I
found was this F looking one no the
first one I found was the a1 the a1 is
the first one I found that was on in the
um then I found the F looking one then
the other F and then the more different
you and then the M what that was it
those totally it no I found the a on the
head and then the F and then the other F
you oh wait no it's um it's putting him
into so one and then the fourth one I
found her God okay so the first one I
found then the fourth one I found then
the second one I found
and the no.1 it was one two three four
yeah three third one I found was that
one knock oh that was a fifth one David
okay uh uh damn it not fog ah ah ah gah
okay I get this okay it was the first
one I found then the fourth one I found
then the second one I found in the fifth
then the last oh come on
maybe the a wasn't the first one maybe
the a was the fourth no maybe they was
the one that did that okay if that was
the first one I found them fourth one I
found was still this one and that means
the second I found was actually this one
third this was oh come on
maybe that's a fourth maybe that one's
ooh maybe that was I don't know I don't
know I don't know ba ba ba ba Bob I know
this one's the fifth one I know that's a
fifth one I know I'm just gonna tart
putting random letters no no no no
that's I know I know I totes mix croats
no that's I know this has gotta be at Oh
ah come on I know I know it's got to be
something here all game a sound that one
two three four five one first one I
found was
yes this is this this this this this
this this
no oh
nah
how many okay let me just try every
possible permutation 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5
but 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 1 2
excuse me while I brute-force through
this going into the future until I get
it 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 oh oh oh ah I
done bad didn't I oh boy
hey there we go
man no one that took a lot longer than I
thought ex mortis cult lures many ha ha
no kidding thank you for world news man
that was good you know I really hate the
atmosphere in that game houses of
anarchy major cities burned that doesn't
seem good
millions died the hands of ex mortis
cult you think you might want to do
something about that all right anyway
man that was ghost like I was really
good at Fenton that's that's been a long
time coming for me personally because it
took me a long time to from the first
time I ever played that to the time now
that I've beaten it um that was a long
long time in the making and sorry for
all the jump cuts um I just didn't I
didn't didn't want you guys to see me
because they were wrong where I was just
trying to get through the thing so
hopefully you guys still enjoyed it
hopefully you guys liked it
um let me know if you want to see the
sequel the super close a more modern
version you can tell that had like 2004
written all over it but either way was
still good so let me know what you guys
thought of it and thank you for watching
click answers it is not done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
no no oh stop back